welcome everybody my name is Professor
Brian Keating and I am the proprietor of
the Dr Brian Keating into the impossible
podcast and YouTube channel so we're
going to be doing this every so often
impossible questions segment and I hope
you'll enjoy it and you'll send in
questions to the Instagram and or
Facebook group drinking Bros nerds and
other uh sessions that we can access and
I will read the questions and I'm
probably quarterly basis and we'll
hopefully get some really stimulating
answers and questions back and forth
next question comes from Mr Abal and he
asks what is the likelihood that if life
developed on a planet similar to Earth
that that life should develop a
recognizable pattern to life on Earth so
that's a good question it's really
talking about astrobiology the study of
life outside of our planet I've done a
lot of talks on my podcast on Dr Brian
Keating on YouTube about aliens and
detecting alien atmospheres and even
detecting the technological imprint of
civilizations via our first form of
Technology on Earth which was
agriculture that's a form of technology
and when you when you are able to
harness the power of biology to
revolutionize to revamp the chemistry
and the atmosphere and the properties of
a planet's surface that in principle
could be detectable from distant places
within the universe in other words we
could detect the pattern of life and
life-forming byproducts of Life on
another planet by looking for kind of
these bio signatures which in turn could
be techno signatures we developed you
know cattle farming and and ranching and
burning of huge forests Etc thousands of
years ago and that could in principle be
visible to a name to an alien
civilization many many light years away
from the Earth
so that would be a type of way that you
could recognize it and the pattern of
life we don't know exactly how life
emerged on Earth let alone how else it
could emerge in the universe so for that
reason we can only speculate from a
sample of one it's quite dangerous but
um but you could expect that there'd be
great consequences to sending actual
other types of life forms throughout the
Universe and so some people speculate
among others folks like Max tegmark
professor at MIT that perhaps the life
that's going around the universe is not
biological carbon based but it's silicon
based it's an artificial intelligence
effectively so that may or may not be
recognizable uh to uh to us and it might
not be even similar to what we consider
to be life here many scientists believe
that life requires liquid water which
places the planet within a certain Zone
called the habitable zone around our
star or a similar star so I think that
that's a quite a good question and we
have to only extrapolate from the sample
of one amidst the perhaps 100 billion
planets in our salt in our in our galaxy
alone on which life could potentially
form a rocky planet not too far not too
close to the Sun that it orbits so for
those reasons uh it's it's a dangerous
perilous thing to try to speculate
nevertheless it's fun to talk about how
you could detect and what that life
would be like uh thank you very much for
tuning into this episode of impossible
answers with yours truly Dr Brian
Keating Chancellor's distinguished
professor of physics and co-director of
the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination at the University of
California San Diego check me out on my
YouTube channel Dr Brian Keating
subscribe to my podcast the into the
impossible podcast please leave ratings
reviews and all that that really helps
me out and we'll do more of these
hopefully like once a quarter we'll
compile your questions and I'll
hopefully give you some answers to
Impossible questions for now signing off
and thanking you very much for being a
part of my Multiverse this is yours
truly Professor Brian